so I want to start at the beginning with
Creed which is strange because I guess
we have to start with the original Rocky
obviously it was the Best Picture winner
it spawned several sequels Ryan when did
you first come up with the idea to tell
the story from Apollo you know the sight
of Apollo Creed and I from what I
understand it's a very personal story to
you yeah I got the idea for do my
lecture with my father he was a big big
hockey fan and he had he got married and
had me and my little brothers when he
was really young so I like my fondest
memories on my dad we're like you know
watching these movies with him and he
would get fired up he would like to jump
up and and you know start doing push-ups
and he was like you know it certain
scenes he would cry you know um and and
my dad was like real tough strong strong
guy from from East Auckland so um always
knew these movies kind of had a magical
effect over you know over my dad you
know so I loved him for that and I'm you
know every will get a VCR you know I
mean they look at the box after him on
that and then we we go for a DVD player
we'll get the box set you know DVDs he
was sailing and watch him you know my
father's day on his birthday you know so
become became a ritual I associated with
him and then um when I was in film
school finishing up my dad got sick
right yeah like I'd like the
neuromuscular disorders they were
struggling to diagnose but he basically
was losing all of his strength and I you
know seeing it seeing him go through
that and having a be there to take care
of him and it really you know really
weighed on me on my heart my mental and
you know I was not came up with the idea
to to maybe tell a story that could
motivate my dad to cheering him up you
know about a hero you know what I was
similar to so I came up with the idea
for Creed the idea of me becoming a
filmmaker was was was it was the
farthest reaching the world so you know
and you know I got into film school was
doing that so you know always in the
back of my mind when I get here buying
ideas
enough figures maybe a possibility for
the reality you'll have anything to lose
you know and earn what was your reaction
I mean when he brought this to you I
have to imagine over the years people
have pitch to ideas I try to avoid him
for a long long time really and then I
saw Fruitvale station and then I heard
that the sly had met with Ryan and was
interested and I've always trusted
sli's instincts from
last 40 years so I met with Orion and I
was very taken with his passion and and
his commitment and Sylvester from what I
understand you took a little convincing
to get back into the ring she was a lot
of humor you know he was very
enthusiastic he came in and I after the
finale of Rocky Balboa I was very happy
with the way the series ended in it
because I didn't think it was ever going
to happen it was probably more difficult
to get that done because we're following
talked about a longshot rocky vibe
didn't work and then 16 years later I
got this idea
the father follow up a film that didn't
work and I got it's really good he's a
60 year old fighter and this is really
gonna wear pajamas in the ring Mecca
really and I said no no but it's not
about boxing so it's it's about curing
yourself it's about venting grief and
when that happened I thought it was a
miracle was literally a miracle that it
got made and was done I was happy with
him
everyone said fine peace be and I
basically hit the last shot of the movie
rocky waves goodbye it was kind of like
in more ways than one and then he digs
me up about eight years later like a
zombie goes come on back from the dead I
have a great idea and what is it oh yeah
well you're you get sick and you're
falling apart no no no because it was
just it was I don't know if we would
really want to see that ass that side I
was everyone's sort of happy at the end
of the movie
know this so the idea that he wanted to
propose I thought okay
sickness well how about if the neighbor
gets sick and rocky or maybe Burt young
yes sir I'll take care of I said I don't
know like it no but anyway yeah I said
no and I surpassed and then he went out
and made food fell session that he came
back and to his credit and his tenacity
that he was offered many many films he
still came back to do the screen which
is sort of a love letter to his father
and a sense of respect and a rite of
passage if so be it and I thought you
know this is this is really
extraordinary enthusiasm and and I just
felt he could do it you know he just he
brought a a worldliness he brought a a a
kind of a sense he understood the
streets he had enthusiasm and and he was
very authentic he just watched Sanok as
a human being and he just delivered and
what did you think about it when he
first told you he wanted to do you know
rocky but from this story of Apollo
Creed's honestly it was like cool yeah
and then we went and started shooting
through good it was it was literally
that quick it was like yeah one thing
where Ryan is once you get to know him
and you know you know you become as
close as we have over the years you just
trust him you know you he in a certain
sense a consulate director it's a
quality that you really you really look
for it you know as an actor it's like
that trust you know in that chemistry
and it's something that we got so he
wouldn't ask me to do anything that he
didn't think was in my best interest so
the fact that he asked I was alright
coolest do it and then so we went to
shot that and then we started focusing
on Adonis and just really like you know
layering that character and figuring out
who he is and his once and you know what
does he need what he's looking for what
is he having you know just like doing
some character breakdown and stuff like
that then the weight of rocky and you
know sly and you know just the legacy in
40 years of just you know these
characters being alive
and stepping into that world that's when
it kind of really you know it started to
you know
me a little bit but after I met slide it
was like you know it was like meeting
one of my uncle's honest it was like
walking in there we're talking about
football in sports and he starts play
fighting and he's rustling he's still
got some strength to him okay you still
got it so we started messing around and
started talking and it was just instant
chemistry man it was just like you know
like I've known this guy you know for
four years and then by the time we
started filming it was like I just
really loved felt stations so Ryan was
somebody that I remember after seeing
that movie I sent an email and made a
phone call and I was like just make sure
that you know what this what this guy is
doing next and then I met him at
Sundance really briefly but I was there
with a film called dear white people and
I didn't know what he was there for at
the time but I guess he was writing I
was at a watch a movie so we met and had
a really kind of brief exchange but it
was after meeting him I guess in the
same way that you talked about was
slightly like you meet someone and
you're like I thought I really wanted to
work with you and now I really want to
work with you
it's just something about and I watched
him for a while on the party lots of
people were kind of coming up to him and
he just had a real way of being very
focused when he's speaking to somebody
that I thought was really unique and
special and and I felt like would make
for a really good director so so then I
just really kind of chased the project
keeping and I didn't know it was a rocky
movie I had no idea what it was really
no not at all because I had seen the
movies but it it wasn't enough versed in
the world that I thought immediately
Creed I was like the band like I didn't
know what I know I had no idea what was
happening I was just like I know he's
making the movie so I just want I don't
know I just want to be in it and then
and then what I knew that Mike was
involved I just thought they had such as
she really should be in the movie not
because of you because I thought that
they had such as a really fantastic
collaboration you know Mike is someone
that's been working a long time and is
very gifted but I feel like what he was
able to do in Fruitvale is because he
was able to do it with somebody that you
just really trusted and you know
so I just kind of kept it on my radar
and then when I had the chance to come
in and read with Mike we did like a
chemistry test and those things are
always awkward because you're like I
don't I hope we have chemistry but we
did we you know we were good we liked
each other well you know I think we have
a tremendous amount of respect for each
other as actors but yeah you had to sing
like all that all the music we knew we
wanted to how to actress you know pull
it off and um I tested came in and it
and crush to actin like we moved like we
know she would and then no sure she's
also a musician herself
so I'm so I mean it was just it was just
perfect getting like right at the or
after you got cast she I caught her and
I was like alright great so so we making
this and she's like yeah let's do it so
much alright go me my composure he's
like at this address because you got to
make like 10 songs she was like cool you
know so she said I went you know it
knocked it out but uh we were really
really fortunate to have her because she
really had her we had our work cut out
you know in many ways you know Tesla's
from no she's from Los Angeles you know
she had to play this character grew up
in Philadelphia very specific place or
whole life you kind of had to buy her as
this you know as it as this woman from
in this environment you know and it was
just all thinking why else could it
could have done what she did
it's it's amazing we've just spent a lot
of time and then you really investigate
what it's like to actually not put on
makeup and and in and assume the
physicality or the pain or they're kind
of like the mortality of of someone who
knows the eminent end is just around the
corner but you just have to look at
people that are really sick and you go
oh my god this isn't makeup this is
their life and you start to flow with
that a little bit and you begin to
identify and empathize and then there's
a sense of resolve like okay this is
this is my fate life how do you handle
your demise to you you go kicking the
screen mean or you accept it and I think
a lot of it has to do with
what have you lost in your life what are
you living for if everything you're
living for is gone then maybe death
isn't so bad you know maybe that's a
welcome reprieve and so all these
different now formulas would be
conquered up and play this one play that
one but the main thing is I really
believe the director sets the tone and
he's very investigative he's also he he
speculates it'll take chances and he'll
let the camera roll and he'll improvise
and then we'll go back to the script and
then eventually you'll find the truth
because you don't stagnate you just keep
moving it around and that is probably
something that it's a gift to born with
to do to be a conductor it's one thing
to be a soloist but he's a conductor and
when people say well why didn't you act
like this years ago as well you know
it's when you have a certain director in
a certain time in your life and it all
comes together yeah it's very rare that
you get those opportunities so I thank
you young man for being born my goodness
thank God you came along